[Music]
so Stephanie you asked a great question
how likely is it that we're gonna find
life on a planet outside the earth in
your lifetime say in the next 40 or 50
years and of course this is something
that nobody can answer exactly we don't
know that's that's the answer but I
think it's very likely indeed now when I
say light there's a lot of ways you can
take that word you know I'm not really
talking about civilizations or
spaceships or things like that I think
it's much more likely that we're going
to find microbes simple life but to me
that will be really really exciting
there are several places in our own
solar system right now that we think
might be good environments for life and
as I said before we haven't found proof
of life yet but we've found some very
very interesting things for example on
Mars Mars has an atmosphere it's much
thinner than the Earth's but is still
there we think there might even be water
underneath the surface of Mars and
recently we've detected organic
molecules which are sort of the building
blocks of our chemistry on Mars as well
it's possible that the surface of Mars
itself is not a very good place for life
but maybe underneath meters under the
soil in the rock you could find bacteria
and there are a lot of analogs to this
on earth similar things on earth we find
bacteria that can exist it's a mild
under the earth we find these things in
gold mines very very deep under the
earth you break open the rocks and
there's actually bacteria living in the
rocks very far down into the earth and
there are other places in the outer
solar system that we think are great
environments for life - there are moons
of Jupiter and Saturn that we know have
liquid water oceans for example Europa
is a moon of Jupiter and we know that
Europa has vast reservoirs of liquid
water that are protected by a shell of
ice in fact it's one moon of Jupiter
Europa actually has far more liquid
water on it than earth does and there
are some suggestions that there might be
interesting chemistry as well there's
also a moon of Saturn called Enceladus
and the same thing applies there's a
liquid water ocean under ice and in the
case of Enceladus you actually have
cracks in the ice that the water is
flying out of and turning into ice
crystals we actually flew our Cassini
space
crafts through these Jets coming out of
Enceladus and we detected organic
molecules so we know that there is warm
saltwater there's interesting chemistry
it's a great place to go looking for
life and there's another moon of Saturn
too called Titan which is very different
from that it has an atmosphere we
actually think that there are lakes of
methane not water but actually liquid
methane on the surface and below that
there's probably liquid water underneath
so you have liquid water you have
organics you have an atmosphere maybe
that'd be a great place to go looking
for some microbes so some people say
that's not very exciting you know we're
not gonna find aliens in the sense of
spaceships and you know Klingons and any
science fiction you want I for one
though I'm gonna be very excited when we
find any evidence of life outside the
earth I actually have a bottle of
champagne chilling because I think it
could happen almost any day when some of
our Rovers are some of our satellites
around other planets come back with
really interesting data think about the
questions we can answer does life even
if it's at a bacterial level even if
it's just a tiny little bit of life does
it have DNA is it similar to us is it
different from us we finally have the
next example of how life can form and
how life can evolve and our view of the
universe will never be the same again
and my bet is that's going to happen in
the next 50 years
[Music]